[Music]
so today's question comes from trevor in
idaho i'm looking for advice on
transitioning between baby steps two and
three
we will be debt-free soon after a 27
month journey my wife wants to celebrate
with a vacation i get that
that would cost around 2 500 however i
want to continue asap on our emergency
fund should i get on board with delaying
the emergency fund for a small vacation
great question trevor so
you know
the the rule of thumb is between baby
steps one and three you're all in
because if you go on vacation and you
only have a thousand dollars in your
emergency fund and something happens
you're kind of screwed so
the idea i mean and maybe you just do
the emergency fund up to two months you
know
three months
three months yeah three to six months of
expenses yeah
here's before the vacation here's the
thing man you you are
yelling
you're yelling into the universe please
kick my butt
when you do this when you go on a
vacation and you don't have an emergency
fund you're asking
for something to break you're inviting
trouble into your home
and i mean it it's just the way it works
i mean the funniest thing is when you
get an emergency fund
you you virtually quit having
emergencies
it's the weirdest thing it's like it's
murphy repellent
and so you don't want to do this man i
mean you're trying your transmission's
going to go out if you do this
it's not you you don't want to do it
it's not worth it so it's not yeah you
know
i get it i whine
too i want to do the editing
and we all whine you know we all have a
whiner inside of us
and your wife is just whining a little
bit and i don't blame her i understand
yeah she all been busting it for 27
months so now you're going to have to
bust it for 32 months and then you're
going to go on vacation
that's what i would do i wouldn't go i i
would be scared
30 years of doing this i can just tell
you it's a weird
statistical thing i have observed that
you are asking for it and maybe and i
always think too trevor what are the
things that you guys can do to to
alleviate some of the like oh he's just
been
busting it so maybe it's like hey once
you because you have you you've paid off
debts maybe it's like once you hit that
one month emergency
into the into the three months like go
on a route go on like two great date
nights like right like kind of scratch
the itch without having to just do it
you know you if you want to spend 300 on
a dinner i'd do that right maybe maybe i
really wouldn't do that but
but i do that before i go on vacation
yes if you've got to do something a
little of the pressure off if you've got
to satisfy the whiner inside of you and
again i'm admitting i have one too okay
so it's not me yelling at you but but if
you kind of gotta go
okay all right we're going to do a
little dinner here and then we're going
to be back game on and then we're never
going to have to be this way again right
beautiful thing about finishing baby
step 3 is you should never have to deal
with it again unless you have a major
emergency and have to recoup your
emergency fund but by the time that
actually happens
you're going to have money so you're
going to be all right but this is like
forever and ever i'm in we are done
don't go back in debt don't ever be
without an emergency fund it changes
everything it gives you the bandwidth
and everything so
i get it
but i think if we can just talk about
this out loud as a couple and go yeah
we're both tired and we're both whiny we
both want to do it but really we this is
time to put your big girl pants on big
boy pants on and suck it up buttercup
you know i mean finish it up well and
there's that it's still the momentum
right so once you're debt free yeah what
what
what was going out to payments like just
keeping that momentum of all that cash
just piling into that emergency fund but
it's hard baby step three
i talked to a lot of people and it's the
hardest it's one of the hearts it's so
boring well it's yes it's just boring
paying off death or some excitement it's
like gotcha your dad right you know but
the others just like get a little money
get a little more money it's just kind
of boring it's totally it's hard and
it's anti-climactic after doing your
debt-free scream you know yeah and yeah
it's just i get it but dude it's
grown-up work it's just adult stuff we
have to do it
and yeah baby steps one through three
until you have that done you got to be
game on rachel's right
so but yeah we're trying to say we
understand but that doesn't mean i would
do it
understanding
feeling the pain with you doesn't mean i
would
you know
put yourself in a baby put yourself put
yourself make yourself vulnerable like
that
because you're just asking for your
stupid tire to blow out and then the
second tire to blow out you know i mean
you got one spare but then the other one
and now you're on the side of the road
and and now vacation looks like a dadgum
movie scene or something it's a
country song you know it's awful
and that's what ends up happening
so it's just interesting to me that when
i was broke i mean stone cold broke no
money which is kind of where you are
right now you're debt-free but you're
broke is is when everything bad happens
but as soon as you start not being broke
it's like this the bad stuff goes next
door to the other neighbor
i mean it's like not all of it but a
bunch of it does
so it turns a crisis into an
inconvenience that's what you always say
about the emergency fund which is true
when you have the money it just kind of
becomes like a uh an eye roll versus it
takes out your whole world